the question is sine two x plus pi on
three equals a half
and then you've got a domain provided
let me ask you this
what immediately strikes you as the
tough part of this question i can see at
least two
uh okay so you've got you've got this
this guy over here
right i'm going to i'm going to lump it
in with the 2x as well what what what do
those do to our graph
the 2x and the pi and 3. they change the
graph in what ways
yeah increase your amplitude from 2 to
negative two and
pi over three will shift it okay so what
three spaces down
so let's let's think about this you're
very very close right
so this pound three is a shift it is a
shift
but it's actually it's going to be a
horizontal shift do you see that it's
close to
modifying the x so it's a left right
it's also what we call a phase shift
okay so it's a left right change um the
2x
is a scale change but it is not a
vertical scale change
it's a what's it gonna do
well it's like it acts like a y-axis
right hmm interesting so i'm hearing
some different languages here
max said something which is it's not the
way i would have said it but it's
closest it makes it thinner it
compresses the graph right
so if you want to think about it this
way if sine x normally looks like this
sine two x is twice as frequent
uh yeah did you draw that enough yeah
they go so it happens more frequently
right so you're going to expect more
solutions than you normally would so
there's the first issue
just um the word dilation
is used here and i'm mentioning that
explicitly
it's the word that you're going to see
okay
and that the dilation factor is
what's happening here yeah this has been
something i'm glad you caught me
this isn't something that's been added
to the new syllabuses so
that that dilation factor there it's a
in particular it's a horizontal
dilation okay that's the first thing i
think is challenging you've got you've
just got all this stuff in the brackets
right what's the other thing that's a
couple
it doesn't equal zero what doesn't equal
zero
oh you mean the equation so is this guy
here okay sure i mean that's that's the
thing that we need to watch for but i'm
gonna suggest
that's fairly standard actually we even
encountered that in the question we just
looked at
see how this is not equal to zero
happens all the time
right there's something else that's on
there and you've literally looked at
everything else so what else
are we missing jermaine
say it again the restrictions look at
these guys right
this is not the standard restriction
we're not we're used to
not to 360 degrees or not to two pi
that's what you will get
like 75 of the time when we want to make
things a bit
trickier um we will change the domain on
you okay so we have to watch out
for both of these now i'm going to say
this right from the outset
um there's lots of different ways to
have a go at this question
i'm going to show you one of them it's
my favorite way but if you're like
that is immediately confusing to me and
i have another way that i feel very
comfortable with that's okay i'll come
and talk to you about that later on
okay here's what i'm going to suggest
it's my first thing
i'm actually going to tackle the domain
first that's a bit of a weird way to go
i'll show you why that is a helpful
thing to do in a minute okay
so see how it says um naught is less
than or equal to x
which is less than or equal to pi okay
i'm going to modify that domain
so that it looks closer to what we've
got over here the thing that's actually
in the brackets okay
so for starters you might notice um
there's a 2x there right you see that
so rather than saying naught is less
than x
i want or equal to x i actually want
there to be a 2x
in there okay so i'm going to take
everything in the inequality
and i'm going to double it so the zero
gets doubled into
zero and the pi gets doubled into
two pi are you okay with that do you
agree that that's an equivalent
inequality
equivalent inequality to what i started
with okay i've doubled everything
so that's changed but there's another
thing to change there's this shift
i've also got to account for okay so i'm
going to add
pi on three to everything in the
inequality right so that gives me pi
on three it's less than equal to two x
plus pi on
three which is less than or equal to
okay let's think for a second
two pi plus pi on three
which i guess would be 420 degrees
what's that in
pies i'm trying to talk in pies
seven pi on three it's seven pi on three
because
this guy is six pi on three do you agree
with that and you added a pi on three so
this is what i'm going to call my
modified
domain right um the question
has a modified uh what we call an
argument this thing in here right
so i'm going to modify them my domain so
it looks more like that
now you're going to see why that's
useful in a second now let's return to
the question
i'm going to think about a simpler
version of this question a question i'm
much better at answering
okay let's just think about if we'll
forget about the 2x spline three for a
minute we'll return to it
let's just think about sine of something
equals a half okay
i think we should be pretty good to just
answer this question straight off the
bat
can anyone tell me the two angles we
should be expecting
okay so if we're thinking in degrees we
would say 30 degrees and the um
the reference sheet will help you there
because sine is opposite
hypotenuse you can see the one over two
there i'm trying desperately not to
think
in degrees so what are the equivalent
radians 30 degrees is
pound six very good okay
now there's another solution right can
anyone tell me what the other solution
is
you can either go for quadrants or you
can go for the graph
it's going to be 150 degrees which is 5
pi on 6
radians okay maybe you just thought of
that yourself maybe you had a friend who
helped you okay so here are my two
solutions just if i were looking at this
basic question okay
now i'm going to show you why modifying
the domain is so helpful
okay do you notice pi on 6 and 5 pi on
six
one of these answers is in my modified
domain and one of them is not
which one is in the domain
the second one the second one's in the
domain five pi on six
right it actually fits between pi on
three and seven pi on three you can
check this on a calculator if you need
or you can go back to degrees mode in
your brain if you like that's 150
degrees
this is i think we said 60 and 420
150 is between those two you okay with
that so you're like good
that one works the first solution is not
in my modified domain can someone tell
me why
because it goes from 60 but that's the
lowest
very good so this is 60 degrees and
above pi on 3 and above
but this is 30 degrees that's that's too
low we're outside
okay so you're like oh this is this is
going to be no good
okay and in fact i hope you can see
there are more solutions to this right
but if you go
more and more negative going the other
direction you're going to not get any of
those solutions being valid do you agree
if if this one is outside the domain
then
everything below that will also be
outside the domain is that okay
so i've got one answer but i'm expecting
there should be more right
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take each of these two solutions
and i'm going to say there's a version
of those that comes up later because
sign just keeps on going right it just
weighs around more and more and more so
remember signs of periodic function what
is its period
how often do you get a whole copy of
sine
it's two pi right it's two pi so if pi
on six is a solution there's another one
just like
it 2 pi radians later
2 pi radians later so 2 pi is
12 pi on 6. do you agree with that so
i'm going to add 12 pi on 6 to this
solution which gives me
that is that okay that's
12 pi on 6 later you'll get another one
for the other solution too
12 pi on 6 later it's going to give you
17
pi on six is that okay so i'm getting
more solution i could keep going if i
wanted there's an infinite number of
these
okay so which which of these is in my
domain is this in my domain
and the answer is it is you can check
this right you can put the numbers in
um 13 on six is less than seven on three
so you're like oh
this one's good is 17 pi on six in my
domain
it will not be again you can check this
on the numbers you've gone too far
okay so now i know not to go too far
that way not to go too far this way
i've got a solution here and a solution
here is that okay now i've done the
hardest part of this
i promise right i've got two solutions i
just need to make them look right
for my actual question i'm not solving
for sine theta
i'm solving for sine this okay so i'm
going to pick back
up where i left off i'm going to write
sine
sorry i'm going to write 2x
plus pi on 3 and i'm going to
put in the two angles you just told me
the ones that work the ones that are in
our modified domain so one of them is 5
pi on 6
and the other one is 13 pi
on 6. these are the answers that will
work and now i just need to do some
algebra okay uh i'm going to make this
all in terms of
pi on 6. so that's 2 pi on 6.
um i'm going to subtract that 2 pi and 6
from
both sides so that gives me 2x here what
do i get for my
solutions here i'm going to subtract
2 pi and 6 from both of them so that's
going to be 3 pi on 6.
does that make sense i subtracted 2.6
from that what about the other one
i'm subtracting 2 pi this is just
fractions right
this will be 11 pi on 6. do you agree
with that
you can see my subtraction what's the
last thing i have to do i don't want 2x
i want
1 x i'm going to divide by 2. very good
so this one
here gives me 3 pi on 12 which i
actually can simplify further
what's the other one if i divide this by
two
11 pi on 12. very good
um i'll do one last simplification
that's pi and four
okay that's a lot of work because this
question had multiple curveballs
in it okay um i know sometimes you might
get to this point and think did i did i
do this right at all
when you are doing questions in your
book and when you're practicing you do
have the luxury of actually checking
right
when i do these kind of questions i just
do it all in numbers
if you feel more comfortable doing this
all in degrees
and you can do that process just please
remember to come back to radians
okay okay well the big one is people
forgetting to come back to
degrees right um let's just quickly
confirm that we've got this answer right
and if you've got your computer there
you're welcome to check this with me
i'm going to put in sine of 2 x
plus pi on 3.
there's my function right i don't want
all of it though i just want part of it
i want to restrict the domain to naught
is less than or equal to x
which is less than or equal to pi okay
so there's the part of the graph that
i'm interested in okay
um i want to know when does that thing
collide with
one over two do you see that
so this is those two spots that i'm
looking for right
there and there and in fact you can even
see desmos immediately tells us
oops here we go it even tells it to you
in pies right
i keep on zooming out those are the two
solutions that we found pi and 4
and 11 pi on 12.
now like i said there are other ways to
do this problem you can think about the
function as one that waves up and down
more frequently
so you don't do the modified domain
approach that i've done
and that will also give you the right
answer but i wanted to show you the way
that i know that
a lot of people get the best success
rate for the students i've taught so
hopefully that is helpful too okay